The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So today hopefully
we will finally
calculate some exponents.
We've been writing,
again and again,
how to calculate partition
functions for systems,
such as a magnet, by
integrating over configurations
of all shapes of a
statistical field.
And we have given weights
to these configurations that
are constructed as some
kind of a function [? l ?]
of these configurations.
And the idea is that
presumably, if I could do this,
then I could figure out
the singularities that
are possible at a place
where, for example, I
go from an unmagnetized
to a magnetized case.
Now, one of the first
things that we noted
was that in general, I can't
solve the types of Hamiltonians
that I would like.
And maybe what I should
do is to break it into two
parts, a part that I will
treat perturbatively,
and a part-- sorry,
a [INAUDIBLE]
part that I can
calculate exactly,
and a contribution that I can
then treat as a perturbation.
Now, we saw that there
were difficulties
if I attempted
straightforward perturbation
type of calculations.
And what we did
was to replace this
with some kind of a
renormalization group approach.
The idea was
something like this,
that these statistical field
theories that we write down
have been obtained by averaging
true microscopic degrees
of freedom over some
characteristic landscape.
So this field m
certainly does not
have fluctuations that
are very short wavelength.
And, for example, if we
were to describe things
in the perspective of
Fourier components,
presumably the variables
that I would have
would have some maximum,
q, that is related
to the inverse of
the wavelength.
So there is some lambda.
And if I were to in fact Fourier
transform my modes in terms
of q, then these modes will be
defined [INAUDIBLE] this space.
And for example,
my beta is zero.
In the language of Fourier
modes would be the part
that I can do exactly, which
is the part that is quadratic
and Gaussian.
And the q vectors would
be between the interval 0
to whatever this lambda is.
And the kind of thing
that I can do exactly
are things that are quadratic.
So I would have m of q squared.
And then some
expansion, [INAUDIBLE]
of q, that has a
constant plus tq squared
and potentially higher
order [INAUDIBLE].
So this is the Gaussian
theory that I can calculate.
Problem with this
Gaussian theory
is that it only is
meaningful for t positive.
And in order to go to the
space where t is negative,
I have to include higher order
terms in the magnetization,
and those are non-perturbative.
And for example, if I go back to
the description in real space,
I was writing something
like um to the fourth
plus higher order terms for
the expansion of this u.
When we attempted to do
straightforward perturbative
calculations, we encountered
some singularities.
And the perturbation
didn't quite make sense.
So we decided to combine
that with the idea
of renormalization group.
The idea there was to basically,
rather than integrate over
all modes, to subdivide
the modes into two
classes, the modes that
are long wavelength
and I would like
to keep, and I'll
call that m tilde, and the
modes that are sitting out here
that I'm not interested
in because they give rise
to no singularities that I
would like to get rid of.
So my integration over
all set of configurations
is really an integration
over both this m tilde
and the sigma.
And if I regard m tilde as
a span over wave numbers
to either be m tilde or
sigma, I can basically
write this as m
tilde plus sigma,
and this is m tilde
plus sigma also.
So this is just a rewriting
of the partition function
where I have just changed
the names of the modes.
Now, the first step in
the renormalization group
is the coarse graining, which
is to average out fluctuations
that have scale between a, and
let's say this in Fourier space
is lambda over b, in real
space would be b times whatever
your original base
scale was for average.
So getting rid of
those modes would
amount to basically changing
the scale over which
you're averaging
by a factor of b.
Once I do that, if I
can do the integration,
what I will be left if
I integrate over sigma
is just an integral
over m tilde.
OK?
Now, what would be the
form of this integration?
The result.
Well, first of all,
if I take the Gaussian
and separate it out between
zero to lambda over b and lambda
over b2 lambda and integrate
over the modes between lambda
over b and lambda, just as
if I had the Gaussian, then
I would get essentially
the contribution
of the logarithm of
the determinants of all
of these Gaussian
types of variances.
So there will be a contribution
to the free energy that
is effectively independent
of m tilde will depend
on the rescaling factor
that you are looking at.
But it's a constant.
It doesn't depend on the
different configurations
of the field m tilde.
The other part of the
Gaussian-- so essentially,
I wrote the Gaussian
as 0 to lambda
over b and lambda
over b2 lambda.
The part that is 0 over
lambda b will simply remain,
so I will have [? beta 8 ?] 0.
That now depends only
on these m tildes.
Well, what do I have
to do with this term?
So it's an integration over
sigma that has to be performed.
I did the integration
by taking out this them
as if it was a Gaussian.
So effectively, the result
of the remaining integration
is the average of
e to the minus u.
And when I take it to the
log, I will get plus log of e
to the minus u, which is a
function of m tilde and sigma,
where I have integrated
out the modes that
are out here, the sigmas.
So it's only a
function of m tilde.
They have been integrated
out using a Gaussian weight,
such as the one that
I have over here.
So that's formally exact.
But it hasn't given
me any insights
because I don't know
what that entity is.
What I can do with
that entity is
to make an expansion
powers of u.
So I will have a minus
the average of u.
And then the next term
would be the variance of u.
So I will have the average of u
squared, average of u squared,
and then higher order terms.
So basically, this term can
be expanded as a power series
as I have indicated.
And again, just to make
sure, these averages
are performed with
this Gaussian weight.
And in particular, we've seen
that when we have a Gaussian
weight, the different components
and the different q values
are independent of each other.
So I get here a delta alpha
beta, I get a delta of q plus q
prime, and I will get
t plus k q squared
and potentially higher
order powers of q
that will appear in this series.
Now, we kind of
started developing
a diagrammatic perspective
on all of this.
Something is m to
the fourth, since it
was the dot product of
two factors of m squared,
we demonstrate it as
a graph such as this.
And we also introduced
a convention
where there solid lines
would correspond to m tilde.
Let's say wavy lines
would correspond to sigma.
And essentially,
what I have to do
is to write this
object according
to this, where each
factor of m is replaced
by two factors, which is the sum
of this entity and that entity
diagrammatically.
So that's two to the four,
or 16 different possibilities
that I could have
once I expand this.
And what was the answer that
we got for the first term
in the series?
So if I take u0 average, the
kind of diagrams that I can get
is essentially keeping
this entity as it is.
So essentially, I will get the
original potential that I have.
Rather than m to the
fourth, I will simply
have the equivalent m
tilde to the fourth.
So basically,
diagrammatically this
would correspond to this entity.
There was a whole bunch
of things that cancel out
to zero in the diagram that
I had with only one leg
when I took the average
because I had a leg by itself,
which would make it an odd
average, would give me zero.
So I didn't have to
put any of these.
And then I had
diagrams where I had
two of the lines
replaced by wavy lines.
And so then I would get
a contribution to u.
There was a factor of 4n
plus-- sorry, 2n plus 4.
That came from
diagrams in which I
took two of the legs
that were together,
and the other two I made wavy,
and I joined them together.
And essentially,
I had the choice
of picking this pair of
legs or that pair of legs,
so that gave me a factor of two.
And something that we will
see again and again, whenever
we have a loop that
goes around by itself,
it corresponds to something
like a delta alpha alpha,
which, when you sum over alpha,
will give you a factor of n.
The other
contribution, the four,
came from diagrams
in which I had
two wavy lines on
different branches.
And since they came originally
from different branches,
there wasn't a repeated helix to
sum and give me a factor of n.
So I just have as
a factor of two
from choice of one branch
or the other branch.
So that was a factor of four.
And then associated with
each one of these diagrams,
there was then an integration
over the index, k,
that characterized
these m tildes,
in fact, the sigmas that
had been integrated over.
So I would have an integral
from lambda over b2 lambda.
Let's call that
dbk 2 pi to the d 1
over the variance, which
is what I have here,
t plus k, k squared,
[INAUDIBLE].
There are diagrams then with
three wavy lines, which again
gave me zero because
the average of three--
average of an odd number with
a Gaussian weight is zero.
And then there were
a bunch of things
that would correspond
to all legs being wavy.
There was something
like this, and there
was something like this.
And basically, I didn't
really have to calculate them.
So I just wrote the
answer to those things
as being a contribution
to the free energy
and overall constant,
such as the constant
that I have over here, but
not at the next order in u,
but independent of
the configurations.
So this was straightforward
perturbation.
I forgot something
very important
here, which is that this
entire coefficient was also
coupled to these solid lines,
whose meaning is that it
is an integral over q 2 pi to
the d m tilde of q squared,
where the waves and
numbers that are sitting
on these solid lines naturally
run from 0 to lambda.
So we can see that if I were to
add this to what I have above,
I see that my z has
now been written
as an integral over
these modes that I'm
keeping of a new weight that
I will call beta h tilde,
depending on these m tildes.
Where this beta h tilde is,
first of all, these terms
that are proportional.
That's with a v here also.
To contributions of
the free energy coming
from the modes that I
have integrated out,
either at the zero order or
at the first order so far.
I have the u, exactly the
same u as I had before,
but now acting on m tilde.
So four factors of m tilde.
The only thing that happened is
that the Gaussian contribution
now running from 0
to lambda over b,
that is proportional to
m tilde of q squared,
is now still a series, such
as the one that I had before,
where the coefficient that
was a constant has changed.
All the other terms
in the series,
the term that is
proportional to q squared,
q to the fourth, et cetera,
are left exactly as before.
So what happened is that this
beta h tilde pretty much looks
like the beta h
that I started with,
with the only difference
being that t tilde is
t plus essentially
what I have over there,
4u n plus 2 integral
lambda over b2 lambda
ddk 2 pi to the d, 1 over t
plus k, k squared, and so forth.
But quite importantly,
the parameter
that I would associate with
coefficient of q squared
is left unchanged.
If I had a coefficient
of q to the fourth,
its coefficient
would be unchanged.
And I have a coefficient for u.
Its coefficient
is unchanged also.
So the only thing
that happened is
that the parameter that
corresponded to t got modified.
And you actually
should recognize this
as the inverse
susceptibility, if I
were to integrate all
the way from 0 to lambda.
And when we did that, this
contribution was singular.
And that's why straightforward
perturbation theory
didn't make sense.
But now we are not
integrating to 0,
which would have
given the singularity.
We are just integrating
over the shell
that I have indicated outside.
So this step was the first
step of renormalization group
that we call coarse graining.
But rg had two other steps.
That was rescale.
Basically, the
theory that I have
has a cut-off that
is lambda over b.
So it looks grainier
in real space.
So what I can do in real
space is to shrink it.
In Fourier space, I have
to blow up my momenta.
So essentially,
whenever I see q,
I replace it with the
inverse q prime so
that q prime, that is bq, runs
from zero to lambda, restoring
the cut-off that
I had originally.
And the next step
was to renormalize,
which amounted to replacing the
field m tilde with a new field
m prime after multiplying or
rescaling by a factor of z
to be determined.
Now, this amounts to simple
dimensional analysis.
So I go back into my equation,
and whenever I see q,
I replace it with
b inverse q prime.
So from the integration, I get
a factor of b to the minus d,
multiplying t tilde, replace
m tilde by z times m prime.
So that's two factors of z.
So what I get is that t prime
is z squared b to the minus d,
this t tilde that I
have indicated above.
Now, k prime is
also something that
appears in the Gaussian term.
So it has a z squared.
It came from two factors of m.
But because it had an
additional factor of q squared
rather than b to the minus d,
it is b to the minus d minus 2.
And I can do the same analysis
for higher order terms going
with higher powers of
q in the expansion that
appears in the Gaussian.
But then we get to
the non-linear terms,
and the first linearity that
we have kept is this u prime.
And what we see is it goes
with four factors of m.
So there will be
z to the fourth.
If I write things
in Fourier space,
m to the fourth in real
space in Fourier space
would involve m of
g1, m of q2, m of q3.
And the fourth m, that is
minus q1, minus q2, minus q3.
But there will be
three integrations
over q, which gives me three
factors of b to the minus 3.
So these are pretty much
exactly what we had already
seen for the Gaussian model--
forgot the k-- except that we
replaced this t that was
appearing for the Gaussian
model with t tilde which
is what I have up here.
Now, you have to choose
z such that the theory
looks as much as possible as
the original way that I had.
And as I mentioned,
our anchoring point
would be the Gaussian.
So for the Gaussian
model, we saw
that the appropriate choice,
so that ultimately we
were left with the right
number of relevant directions
was to set this
combination to 1, which
means that I have
to choose z to be
v to the power of
1 plus d over 2.
Now, once I choose
that factor for z,
everything else
becomes determined.
This clearly has two factors of
b with respect to the original.
So this becomes b squared.
This you have to do
a little bit of work.
Z to the fourth
would be b to the 4
plus 2d, then minus 3d
gives me b to the 4 minus d.
And I can similarly determine
what the dimensions would
be for additional terms
that appear in the Gaussian,
as well as additional
nonlinearities that
could appear here.
All of them, by this analysis,
I can assign some power of b.
So this completes
the rg in the sense
that at least at this order
in perturbation theory,
I started with my
original theory,
and I see how the
parameters of the new theory
are obtained if I were to
rescale and renormalize
by this factor of b.
Now, we did one thing else,
which is quite common,
which is rather than
choosing factors
like b equals to 2 or 3, making
b to be infinitesimally small,
at least on the picture
that I have over there.
What I'm doing is I'm
making this b very close
to 1, which means
that effectively I'm
putting the modes
that I'm getting
rid of in a tiny
shell around lambda.
So I have chosen b to be
slightly larger than 1
by an amount delta l.
And I expect that
all of the parameters
will also change
very slightly, such
that this t prime
evaluated at scale v
would be what I had
originally, plus something
that vanishes as
delta l goes to zero
and presumably is linear
in delta l dt by dl.
And similarly, I can
do the same thing for u
and all the other
parameters of the theory.
Once I do that, these
jumps from one parameter
to another parameter can
be translated into flows.
And, for example, dt by
dl gets a contribution
from writing b squared
as 1 plus 2 delta l.
That is proportional
to 2 times t.
And then there's
another contribution
that is order of delta l.
Clearly, if b equals to 1,
this integral would vanish.
So if b is very close
to 1, this integral
is off the order of delta l.
And what it is is just
evaluating the integrand when
k equals to lambda at the
shell, and then multiplying
by the volume of
that shell, which
is the surface area
times the thickness.
So I will get from here a
contribution order of delta l.
I have divided through by
delta l, which is 4u m plus 2 1
over t plus k lambda squared
[INAUDIBLE] integrand.
And then I have the surface
area divided by 2 pi to the d
that we have always called kd.
And then lambda to
the d is the product
of lambda to the d
minus 1 and lambda
delta l, which comes
from the thickness.
The delta l I have taken out.
And this whole thing is the
order of u contribution.
And then they had
a term that is du
by dl, which is 4
minus d times u.
So this is the result of
doing this perturbative rg
to the lowest order
in this parameter u.
Now, these things are really
the important parameters.
There will be other parameters
that I have not specifically
written down.
And next lecture, we will
deal with all of them.
But let's focus on these two.
So I have one
parameter, which is
t, the other
parameter, which is u.
But u can only be positive
for the theory to make sense.
I said that originally the
Gaussian theory only makes
sense if t is positive because
once t becomes negative,
then the weight gets shifted
to large values of m.
It is unphysical.
So for physicalness of
the Gaussian theory,
I need to confine myself
to the t positive plane.
Now that I have u, I can
have t that is negative
and um to the fourth,
as long as u positive,
will make the
weight well behaved.
So this entire plane
is now accessible.
Within this plane,
there is a point
which corresponds to
a fixed point, a point
that if I'm at that location,
then the parameters no longer
change.
Clearly, if u does not change, u
at the fixed point should be 0.
If u at the fixed point is
0 and t does not change,
t at the fixed point is 0.
So this is the fixed point.
Since I'm looking at a
two-dimensional projection,
there will be two
eigendirections associated
with moving away from
this fixed point.
If I stick with the
axis where u is 0,
you can see that u will stay 0.
But then dt by dl is 2t.
So if I'm on the axis
that u equals to 0,
I will stay on this axis.
So that's one of
my eigendirections.
And along this
eigendirection, I will
be flowing out with
an eigenvalue of 2.
Now, in general however, let's
say if I go to t equals to 0,
you can see that if t is
0, but u positive dt by dl
is positive.
So basically, the
u direction you
will be going if you start
on the t equals to 0 axis,
you will generate a positive t.
And the typical
flows that you would
have would be in this direction.
Actually, I should draw
it with a different color.
So quite generically,
the flows are like this.
But there is a direction along
which the flow is preserved.
So there is a straight line.
This straight line you can
calculate by setting dt
by dl divided by du by dl
to be the ratio of t over u.
You can very easily
find that it corresponds
to a line of t
being proportional
to u with a negative slope.
And the eigenvalue
along that direction
is determined by 4 minus d.
So that the picture that I
have actually drawn for you
here corresponds to
dimensions greater than four.
In dimensions greater than four
along this other direction,
you will be flowing
towards the fixed point.
And in general, the flows
look something like this.
So what does that mean?
Again, the whole thing
that we wrote down
was supposed to
describe something
like a magnet at
some temperature.
So when I fix my
temperature of the magnet,
I presumably reside at
some particular point
on this diagram.
Let's say in the
phase that is up here,
eventually I can see that I
go to large t and u goes to 0.
So the eventual weight is
very much like a Gaussian,
e to the tm squared over 2.
So this is essentially
independent patches
of the system randomly pointing
to different directions.
If I change my system to
have a lower temperature,
I will be looking at
a point such as this.
As I lower the
temperature, I will
be looking at some
other point presumably.
But all of these
points that correspond
to lowering
temperatures, if I also
now look at increasing land
scale, will flow up here.
Presumably, if I
go below tc, I will
be flowing in the other
direction, where t is negative,
and then the u is
needed for stability,
which means that I have
to spontaneously choose
a direction in which
I order things.
So the benefit of doing this
renormalization and this study
was that in the absence
of u, I could not
achieve the low temperature
part of the system.
With the addition of u, I
can describe both sides,
and I can see on the
rescaling which set of points
go to what is the analog of
the high temperature, which
set of points go to what is
the analog of low temperature.
And the point that
corresponds to the transition
between the two is on the basing
of attraction of the Gaussian
fixed point that
is asymptotically,
the theory would be described
by just gradient of m squared.
But this picture does
not work if I go too
d that is less than four.
And d less than four,
I can again draw u.
I can draw t.
And I will again find
the fixed point at 0, 0.
I will again find
an eigendirection,
at u equals to 0, which pushes
things out along the u equals
to 0 axis.
Going from d of above
four to d of below four
does not really
materially change
the location of this other
eigendirection by much.
It pretty much
stays where it was.
The thing that it does
change is the eigenvalue.
So basically, here I
will find that the flow
is in this direction.
And if I were to generalize
the picture that I have,
I would get things that
would be going like this
or going like this.
Once again, there are
a set of trajectories
that go on one side,
that go on the other side.
And presumably, by
changing temperature,
I will cross from one
set of trajectories
to the other set
of trajectories.
But the thing is
that the point that
corresponds to hitting the
basin that separates the two
sets of trajectories, I don't
know what it corresponds to.
Here, for d greater
than 4, it went
to the Gaussian fixed point.
Here currently, I don't
know where it is going.
So I have no understanding at
this level of what the scale
invariant properties are
that describe magnets
in three dimensions at
their critical temperature.
Now, the thing is that the
resolution and everything
that we need comes from
staring more at this expansion
that we had.
We can see that this is an
alternating theory because I
started with e to the minus u.
And so the next term is likely
to have the opposite sign
to the first term.
So I anticipate that at the end
of doing the calculation, if I
go to the next order,
there will be a term here
that is minus vu squared.
Actually, there will be a
contribution to dt by dl also
that is minus, let's
say, au squared.
So I expect that if I were to
do things at the next order,
and we will do that
in about 15 minutes,
I will get these kinds of terms.
Once I have that
kind of term, you
can see that I anticipate
then a fixed point occurring
at the location u star, which
is 4 minus d divided by b.
And then, by looking in the
vicinity of this fixed point,
I should be able to
determine everything
that I need about
the phase transition.
But then you can ask, is this
a legitimate thing to do?
I have to make sure I do
things self consistently.
I did a perturbation
theory assuming
that u is a small quantity,
so that I can organize things
in power of u, u
squared, u cubed.
But what does it mean that I
have control over powers of u?
Once I have landed at this
fixed point, where at the fixed
point, u has a value that
is fixed and determined.
It is this 4 minus d over b.
So in order for the series
to make sense and be
under control, I
need this u star
to be under control
as a small parameter.
So what knob do I have
to ensure that this u
star is a small parameter?
Turns out that practically
the only knob that I have
is that this 4 minus
d should be small.
So I can only make this
into a systematic theory
by making it into an expansion
in a small quantity, which
is 4 minus d.
Let's call that epsilon.
And now we can hopefully,
at the end of the day,
keep track of appropriate
powers of epsilon.
So the Gaussian theory
describes properly
the behavior at four dimensions.
At 4 minus epsilon
dimensions, I can
figure out where
this fixed point is
and calculate things correctly.
All right?
So that means that I need
to do this calculation
of the variance of u.
So what I will do here
is to draw a diagram
to help me do that.
So let's do something like this.
OK, let's do
something like this.
Six, seven rows
and seven columns.
The first row is to just tell
you what we are going to plot.
So basically, I need
a u squared average,
which means that I need
to have two factors of u.
Each one of them depends
on m tilde and sigma.
And so I will
indicate the two sets.
Actually already,
we saw when we were
doing the case of the
first order calculation,
how to decompose this
object that has four lines.
And we said, well, the first
thing that I can do is to just
use the m's.
The next thing
that I can do is I
could replace one of
the m's with a sigma.
And there was a choice
of four ways to do so.
Or I could choose to replace
two of the m's with wavy lines.
And question was, the right
branch or the left branch?
So there's two of these.
I could put the wavy lines
on two different branches.
And there was four
ways to do this one.
I could have three wavy
lines, and the one solid line
could then be in one
of four positions.
Or I had all wavy
lines, so there is this.
So that's one of my factors of u
on the vertical for this table.
On the horizontal, I
will have the same thing.
I will have one of these.
I will have four of these.
I will have two of these.
I will have four of these, and
one which is all wavy lines.
Now I have to put
two of these together
and then do the average.
Now clearly, if I put
two of these together,
there's no average to be done.
I will get something that
is order of m to the fourth.
But remember that I'm
calculating the variance.
So that would subtract
from the average squared
of the same quantity.
It's a disconnected piece.
And I have stated that
anything that is disconnected
will not contribute.
And in particular, there is no
way to join this to anything.
So everything that we
log here in this row
would correspond
to no contribution
once I have subtracted out
the average of u squared.
And there is symmetry
in this table.
So the corresponding
column is also
all things that are
disconnected entities.
All right.
Now let's see the next one.
I have a wavy line here, a
sigma here, and a sigma here.
I can potentially
join them together
into a diagram that looks
something like this.
So I will have this, this.
I have a leg here.
I will have this line
gets joined to that line.
And then I have
this, this, this.
Now, what is that beast?
It is something that has
six factors of m tilde.
So this is something
that is order
of m tilde to the sixth power.
So the point is
that we started here
saying that I should
put every term that
is consistent with symmetry.
I just focused on the
first fourth order term,
but I see this is one
of the things that
happens under
renormalization group.
Everything that is
consistent with symmetry,
even if you didn't put it
there at the beginning,
is likely to appear.
So this term appeared
at this order.
You have to think of
ultimately whether that's
something to worry about or not.
I will deal with that next time.
It is not something
to worry about.
But let's forget about
that for the time being.
Next term, I have one wavy line
here and two wavy lines there.
So it's something
that is sigma cubed.
Against the Gaussian
weight, it gives me 0.
So because of it being an odd
term, I will get a 0 here.
What color [INAUDIBLE] a 0 here.
Somehow I need this row
to be larger in connection
with future needs.
Next one is also
something that involves
three factors of sigma,
so it is 0 by symmetry.
And again, since this
is a diagram that
has symmetry along the diagonal,
there will be 0's over here.
Next diagram.
I can somehow join
things together
and create something
that has four legs.
It will look
something like this.
I will have this leg.
This leg can be joined,
let's say, with this leg,
giving me something out here.
And these two wavy lines
can be joined together.
That's a possibility.
You say, OK.
This is a diagram
that corresponds
to four factors of m tilde.
So that should
contribute over here.
Actually, the answer
is that diagram is 0.
The reason for that
is the following.
Let's look at this
vortex over here.
It describes four momenta
that have come together.
And the sum of the
four has to be 0.
Same thing holds here.
The sum of these
four has to be 0.
Now, if we look at
this diagram, once I
have joined these
two together, I
have ensured that the
sum of these two is 0.
The sum of all of four is 0.
The sum of these two is 0.
So the sum of these
two should be 0 too.
But that's not allowed.
Because one of them is outside
this shell, and the other
is inside the shell.
So just kinematically,
there's no choice of momenta
that I could make that would
give a contribution to this.
So this is 0 because
of what I will
write as momentum
type of conservation.
Again, because of that, I
will have here as 0 momentum
down here.
The next diagram has one sigma
from here and four sigmas.
So that's an odd
number of sigmas.
So this will be 0
too, just because
of up-down symmetry in m tilde.
So we are gradually getting
rid of places in this table.
But the next one is
actually important.
I can take these two and
join them to those two
and generate a diagram
that looks like this.
So I have these two hands.
These two hands get joined to
the corresponding two hands.
And I have a diagram
such as this.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Is
there another way for them
to join also?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
there is another way
which suffers exactly
the same problem.
Ultimately, because you
see the problem is here.
I will have to join
two of them together,
and the other two
will be incompatible.
Now, just to sort of give you
ultimately an idea, associated
with this diagram there will be
a numerical factor of 2 times 2
from the horizontal times
the vertical choices.
But then there's
another factor of 2
because this diagram
has two hands.
The other diagram has two hands.
They can either join like this,
or they can join like this.
So there's two possibilities
for the crossing.
If you kind of look ahead to
the indices that carry around,
these two are part
of the same branch.
They carry the same index.
These two would be carrying
the same index, let's say j.
the same index, j prime.
So when I do the sum, I
will have a sum over j
and j prime of delta j, j prime.
I will have a sum
over j delta jj, which
will give me a factor of n.
Any time you see a closed loop,
you generate a factor of n,
just like we did over here.
It generated a factor of n.
OK, so there's that.
The next diagram looks
similar, but does not
have the factor of n.
I have from over there the two
hands that I have to join here.
I have to put my
hands across, and I
will get something like this.
So it's a slightly
different-looking diagram.
The numerical factor that goes
with that is 2 times 4 times 2.
There is no factor of n.
Now, again, because
of symmetry, there's
a corresponding entity
that we have over here.
If I just rotate that,
I will essentially
have the same diagram.
Opposite way, I have
essentially that.
The two hands reach
across to these
and give me something
that is like this.
To that, sorry.
They join to that one.
And the corresponding
thing here looks like this.
Numerical factors, this
would be 2 times 4 times 2.
It is exactly the same as this.
This would be 4 times 4 times 2.
At the end of the day,
I will convince you
that this block of four diagrams
is really the only thing
that we need to compute.
But let's go ahead and
see what else we have.
If I take this thing
that has two hands,
try to join this thing
that has three hands,
I will get, of course,
0, based on symmetry.
If I take this term
with two hands,
join this thing
with four hands, I
will generate a
bunch of diagrams,
including, for
example, this one.
I can do this.
There are other diagrams also.
So these are ultimately diagrams
with two hands left over.
So they will be contributions
to m tilde squared.
And they will indeed
give me modifications
of this term over here.
But we don't need
to calculate them.
Why?
Because we want to do
things consistently
to order of epsilon.
In the second equation, we
start already with epsilon u.
So this term was order
of epsilon squared.
Since u star will
be order of epsilon,
this term will be
epsilon squared.
The two terms I
have to evaluate,
they are both of the same order.
But in the first
equation, I already
have a contribution that
is order of epsilon.
If I'm calculating things
consistently to lowest order,
I don't need to calculate
this explicitly.
I would need to
calculate it explicitly
if I wanted to calculate
things to order
of epsilon squared, which
I'm not about to do.
But to our order,
this diagram exists,
but we don't need to evaluate.
Again, going because of the
symmetry along the diagonal
of the diagram, we
have something here
that is order of m tilde
squared that we don't evaluate.
OK, let's go further.
Over here, we have two
hands, three hands.
By symmetry, it will be zero.
Over here, we have
two hands, four hands.
I will get a whole
bunch of other things
that are order of
m tilde squared.
So there are other terms that
are of this same form that
would modify the
factor of a, which
I don't need to
explicitly evaluate.
All right.
What do we have left?
There is a diagram here
that is interesting
because it also gives
me a contribution that
is order of m tilde squared,
which we may come back to
at some point.
But for the time being,
it's another thing
that gives us a
contribution to a.
Here, what do we have?
We have three hands, four
hands, zero by symmetry,
zero by symmetry.
Down here, we have
no solid hands.
So we will get a whole
bunch of diagrams,
such as this one, for
example, other things, which
collectively will
give a second order
correction to the free energy.
It's another constant that
we don't need to evaluate.
So let's pick one of
these diagrams, this one
in particular, and
explicitly see what that is.
It came out of putting
two factors of u together.
Let's be explicit.
Let's call the momenta
here q1, q2, and k1, k2.
And the other u here came
from before I joined them,
there was a q3, q4.
There was a k1 prime, k2 prime.
So let's say the first
u-- this is a diagram that
will contribute at
order of u squared.
Second order terms
in the series all
come with a factor of one half.
It is u to the n
divided by n factorial.
So this would be explicitly
u squared over 2.
For the choice of
the left diagram,
we said there were
two possibilities.
For the choice of
right diagram, there
were two branches, one of
which I could have taken.
In joining the two
hands together,
I had a degeneracy of two,
so I have all of that.
A particular one of these
is an integral over q1, q2.
And from here, I would have
integrations over q3, q4.
These are all
integrations that are
for variables that are
in the inner shell.
So this is lambda
to lambda over b.
I have integrations from
lambda over v2 lambda
for the variables k1,
k2, k1 prime, k2 prime.
And if I explicitly
decided to write all four
momenta associated with
a particular index,
I have to explicitly include
the delta functions that
say the sum of the momenta
has to add up to 0.
Now, what I did was to drawing
these two sigmas together.
So I calculated one of
those Gaussian averages
that I have over there.
Actually, before
I do that, I note
that these pairs
are dotted together.
So I have m tilde of
q1 dotted with m tilde
of q3, m tilde of q4 dotted
with m tilde of q1, q2, q3, q4.
These two are dot products.
Here, I joined the
two sigmas together.
The expectation
value gives me 2 pi
to the d at delta
function k1 plus k1
prime divided by t plus k,
k1 squared, and so forth.
And the delta
function, if I call
these indices j, j,
j prime, j prime,
I will have a delta j j prime.
And from the lower two that
I have connected together,
I have 2 pi to the d delta
function k2 plus k2 prime.
Another delta j j prime, t plus
k, k2 squared, and so forth.
Now I can do the integrations.
But first of all, numerical
factors, I will get 4u squared.
As I told you, delta j
j prime, delta j j prime
will give me delta jj.
Sum over j, I will
get a factor of n.
That's the n that I
anticipated and put over there.
I have the integrations 0 to
lambda over v, ddq1, ddq2,
ddq3, ddq4, 2 pi to the 4d.
And then this m tilde
q1 m tilde q2 m tilde q3
dotted with m tilde q4.
Now, note the following.
If I do the integration
over k1 prime,
k1 prime is set to minus k1.
If I do the integration
over k2 prime,
k2 prime is set to minus k2.
If I now do the
integration over k2,
k2 is set to minus q1
minus q2 minus k1, which
if I insert over here, will give
me a delta function that simply
says that the four external
q's have to add up to 0.
So there is one integration
that is left, which is over k1.
So I have to do
the integral lambda
over v2 lambda, dd
of k1 2 pi to the d.
So basically, there's k1 running
across the upper line gives me
a factor of 1 over t plus
k, k1 squared, and so forth.
And then there is
what is running
along the bottom line,
which is k2 squared.
And k2 squared is the
same thing as q1 plus q2
plus k1, the whole
thing squared.
So the outcome of
doing the averages that
appear in this
integral is to generate
a term that is proportional
to m to the fourth, which
is exactly what we
had, with one twist.
The twist is that
the coefficient that
is appearing here actually
depends on q1 and q2.
Of course, q1 and q2
being inner momenta
are much smaller than k1, which
is one of the shared momenta.
So in principle,
I can expand this.
I can expand this as
ddk 2 pi to the d lambda
over b2 lambda, 1 over
t plus k, k squared.
I've renamed k1 to k squared to
lowest order in q, this is 0.
And then I can expand this thing
as 1 plus k q1 plus q2 squared
and so forth,
divided by t plus k k
squared raised to
the minus 1 power.
Point is that if I
set the q's to 0,
I have obtained a
constant addition
to the coefficient of
my m to the fourth.
But I see that further
down, I have generated also
terms that depend on q.
What kind of terms
could these be?
If I go back to
real space, these
are terms that are
after order of m
to the fourth, which was, if you
remember, m squared m squared.
But carry additional
gradients with them.
So, for example, it could
be something like this.
It has two factors of
q, various factors of n.
Or it could be something like m
squared gradient of m squared.
The point is that we have
again the possibility, when
we write our most general
term, to introduce
lots and lots of non-linearities
that I didn't explicitly
include.
But again, I see, if I
forget them at the beginning,
the process will
generate them for you.
So I should have really
included these types of terms
in the beginning because they
will be generated under the RG,
and then I can track
their evolution of all
of the parameters.
I started with 0 for
this type of parameter.
I generated it out of nothing.
So I should really go
back and put it there.
But for the time being,
let's again ignore that.
And next time, I'll
see what happens.
So what we find at
the end of evaluating
all of these diagrams is that
this beta h tilde evaluated
at the second
order, first of all,
has a bunch of constants
which in principle, now
we can calculate
to the next order.
Then we find that
we get terms that
are proportional to m tilde
squared, the Gaussian.
And I can get the terms that
I got out of second order
and put it here.
So I have my
original t tilde now
evaluated at order of u squared.
Because of all those diagrams
that I said I have to do.
I will get a k tilde q
squared and so forth,
all of them multiplying
m tilde squared.
And I see that I
generated terms that
are of the order of m
tilde to the fourth.
So I have ddq1,
ddq4, 2 pi to the 4d,
2 pi to the d delta function,
q1, q4, m tilde q1, m tilde q2,
m tilde q3, m tilde q4.
And what I have to
lowest order is u.
And then I have a
bunch of terms that
are of the form
something like this.
So they are corrections
that are proportional
to the integral lambda
over b lambda ddk 2 pi
to the d, 1 over t plus
k, k squared squared.
So essentially, I took
this part of that diagram.
That diagram has a
contribution at order
of u squared, which is 4n.
So if I had written it
as u squared over 2,
I would have put
8n, the 8 coming
from just the multiplication
that I have there, 2 times
2 times 2 times n.
Now, if you calculate
the other three diagrams
that I have boxed,
you'll find that they
give exactly the same
form of the contribution,
except that the numerical
factor for them is different.
I will get 16, 1632, adding
up together to a factor of 64
here.
And then the point is that I
will generate additional terms
that are, let's say,
order of q squared
and so forth,
Which are the kinds
of terms that I
had not included.
So what we find is
that-- question?
AUDIENCE: Where did
you add the t total?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's maybe write
this explicitly.
So what would be the coefficient
that I have to put over here?
I have t at the 0-th order.
At order of u, I calculated
4u n plus 2 integral.
The point is that when I
add up all of those diagrams
that I haven't
explicitly calculated,
I will get a correction
here that is order
of u squared whose
coefficient I will call a.
But then this is the 0-th
order in the momenta,
and then I have to
go and add terms
that are at the order of q
squared and higher order terms.
So this was, again, the
course graining step
of RG, which is the hard part.
The rescaling and
renormalization are simple.
And what they give me
at the end of the day
are the modifications
to dt by dl and du
by dl that we expected.
dt by dl we already wrote.
0-th order is 2t.
First order is a correction.
4u n plus 2 integral, which,
when evaluated on the shell,
gives me kt lambda to
the d t plus k lambda
squared and so forth.
Now, this a here would
involve an integration.
Again, this integration
I evaluated on the shell.
So the answer will
be some a that
will depend on t,
k, and other things,
would be a contribution
that is order of u squared.
I haven't explicitly
calculated what this a is.
It will depend on all of
these other parameters.
Now, when I calculate the u
by dl, I will get this 4 minus
d times u to the lowest order.
To the next order, I
essentially get this integral.
So I have minus 4n minus
4n plus 8 u squared.
Evaluate that
integral on the shell.
kd lambda to the
d t plus k lambda
squared and so forth squared.
And presumably,
both of these will
have corrections at
higher orders, order
of u squared, et cetera.
So this generalizes the
picture that we had over here.
Now we can ask, what
is the fixed point?
In fact, there will
be two of them.
There is the old Gaussian
fixed point at t star
u star equals to 0.
Clearly, if I said t and u
equals to 0, I will stay at 0.
So the old fixed
point is still there.
But now I have a
new fixed point,
which is called the ON fixed
point because it explicitly
depends on the
symmetry of the order
parameter, the number
of components, n,
as well as dimensionality.
It's called the ON fixed point.
So setting this to 0, I will
find that u star is essentially
epsilon divided by
whatever I have here.
I have 4n plus 8
kd lambda to the d.
In the numerator,
I would have t star
plus k lambda squared squared.
And then I can
substitute that over here
to find what t star is.
So t star would be minus 2
n plus 2 kd lambda to the d
divided by t star
plus k lambda squared,
et cetera, times u star, which
is what I have the line above,
which is t star plus
k lambda squared,
et cetera, squared, divided by
4n plus 8 kd lambda to the t.
Now, over here,
this is in principle
an implicit equation for t star.
But I forgot the epsilon
that I have here.
But it is epsilon multiplying
some function of t star.
So clearly, t star
is order of epsilon.
And I can set t star equal to
0 in all of the calculation,
if I'm calculating things
consistently to epsilon.
You can see that this kd
lambda to the d cancels that.
One of these factors cancels
what I have over here.
At the end of the day, I will
get minus n plus 2 divided
by n plus 8 k lambda
squared epsilon.
And similarly, over here
I can get rid of t star
because it's already
order of epsilon,
and I have epsilon out here.
So the answer is going
to be k squared lambda
to the power of 4 minus
d divided by 4n plus
8 kd lambda to the d.
Presumably, both of these
plus order of epsilon squared.
So you can see that,
as anticipated,
there's a fixed
point at negative 2 t
star and some particular u star.
There was a question.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What is unnecessary?
AUDIENCE: You already
did 4 minus [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: The u started.
Yeah, that one.
PROFESSOR: Here.
AUDIENCE: Erase it.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
lambda to the d is 0.
Right.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: For t star,
does factor of 2.
PROFESSOR: t star, does
it have a factor of 2?
Yes, 2 divided by 4.
There is a factor of 2 here.
Thank you.
Look at this.
You don't really see
much to recommend it.
The interesting
thing is to find what
happens if you are not
exactly at the fixed point,
but slightly shifted.
So we want to see what happens
if t is t star plus delta t,
u is u star plus delta u,
if I shift a little bit.
If I shift a little bit,
linearizing the equation
means I want to know
how the new shifts are
related to the old shift.
And essentially doing
things at the linear level
means I want to construct a
two-by-two matrix that relates
the changes delta t delta
u to the shifts originally
of delta t and delta u.
What do I have to
do to get this?
What I have to do is to take
derivatives of the terms for dt
by dl with respect to
t, with respect to u.
Take the derivative
with respect to t.
What do I get?
I will get two.
I will get minus 4u n plus 2
kd lambda to the father of d
divided by t plus k
lambda squared squared.
So the derivative of 1 over t
became minus 1 over t squared.
There is a second order term.
So there will be a derivative
of that with respect
to t multiplying u squared.
I want you to calculate it.
Delta u, if I make
a change in u,
there will be a shift
here, which is 4n
plus 2 kd lambda
to the d divided
by t plus k lambda squared.
From the second order
term, I will get minus 2au.
For the second equation,
if I take the derivative
of this variation in t, I will
get a plus 4n plus 8u squared
kd lambda to the d t
plus k lambda squared
and so forth cubed.
And the fourth place, I will
get epsilon minus 8 n plus 8 kd
lambda to the d u divided
by t plus k lambda
squared and so forth squared.
Now, I want to evaluate this
matrix at the fixed point.
So I have to linearize in
the vicinity of fixed point.
Which means that I put the
values of t star and u star
everywhere here.
And then I have to calculate
the eigenvalues of this matrix.
Now, note that this
element of the matrix
is proportional
to u star squared.
So this is certainly
evaluated at the fixed point
order of epsilon squared.
Order of epsilon
squared to me is zero.
I don't see order
of epsilon squared.
So I can get rid of this.
Think of a zero
here at this order.
Which means that
the matrix now has
zeroes on one side of
the diagonal, which
means that what
is appearing here
are exactly the eigenvalues.
Let's calculate
the eigenvalue that
corresponds to this element.
I will call it yu.
It is epsilon minus 8 n plus
8 kd lambda to the d t star.
Well, since I'm calculating
things to order of epsilon,
I can ignore that
t star down there.
I have k squared lambda
to the four or k squared,
lambda squared, and
so forth squared.
Multiplied by u star.
Where is my u star?
u star is here.
So it is multiplied by n plus 2.
Sorry, my u star is up here.
k squared lambda to the 4
minus d 4 n plus 8 kd epsilon.
Right.
Now the miracle happens.
So k squared cancels
the k squared.
Lambda to the four
and lambda to the d
cancel this lambda
to the four minus d.
The kd cancels the kd.
The n plus 8 cancels
the n plus a.
8 cancels the 2.
The answer is epsilon
minus 2 epsilon,
which is minus epsilon.
OK?
[LAUGHTER]
So this direction has
become irrelevant.
The epsilon here turn
to a minus epsilon.
This irrelevant
direction disappeared.
There is this relevant
direction that is left,
which is a slightly
shifted version of what
my original [INAUDIBLE]
direction was.
And you can calculate yt.
So you go to that
expression, do the same thing
that I did over here.
You'll find that at
the end of the day,
you will find 2 minus n plus
2 over n plus 8 epsilon.
All these unwanted things, like
kd's, these lambdas, et cetera,
disappear.
You expected at the end of
the day to get pure numbers.
The exponents are pure numbers.
They don't depend on anything.
So we had to carry
all of this baggage.
And at the end of the day, all
of the baggage miraculously
disappears.
We get a fixed point that has
only one relevant direction,
which is what we always wanted.
And once we have
the exponent, we
can calculate
everything that we want,
like the exponent for
divergence of correlation length
is the inverse of that.
You can calculate how it
has shifted from one half.
It is something like n plus
2 over n plus 8 epsilon.
And we see that the exponents
now explicitly depend
on dimensionality of space
because of this epsilon.
They explicitly
depend on the number
of components of your
order parameter n.
So we have managed, at least
in some perturbative sense,
to demonstrate that there exists
a kind of scale invariance
that characterizes this
ON universality class.
And we can calculate
exponents for that, at least
perturbatively.
In the process of
getting that number,
I did things rapidly
at the end, but I also
swept a lot of
things under the rug.
So the task of next lecture is
to go and look under the rug
and make sure that we haven't
put anything that is important
away.